this presentation is delivered by the
Stanford center for professional
development good evening to everyone if
I could get your attention and would
like to go ahead and get started so I'm
Jim plumber the Dean of the engineering
school let me begin by welcoming all of
you here we're just delighted to have a
great crowd here in invidi auditorium
and there are hundreds more Stanford
alums and friends who are watching the
event this evening wear because it's
being webcast throughout the world we're
here of course to honor Craig Barrett
who I will introduce in just a moment
who is being inducted as one of our
Stanford engineering heroes and I wanted
to say just a little bit about the
Stanford engineering Heroes program this
is a program that we started a couple
years ago actually and it recognizes
intended to recognize the achievements
of Stanford engineers who have
profoundly advanced the course of human
social and economic progress through
engineering there are 16 people so far
that we have named engineering heroes
and we plan on naming additional heroes
each year going forward fact the next
class I think will be announced in
another month or so but in being named
an engineering hero tonight Craig joins
a really quite distinguished group of
people and includes Fred Terman bill
bill hewlett david packard vint cerf gps
creator brad Parkinson and sun
microsystems co-founder andy
bechtolsheim among others there's a wall
just out back and down to the right that
has plaques listed for all of the
engineering heroes so unlike many events
like this all we really ask of people
who wish to honor in this way is that
they tell us how they would like to
spend a day or part of a day at Stanford
and we try and and set something up that
that is exciting for them and
interesting for all of us as well so
Craig suggested that he'd like to spend
some time with some students and not
surprisingly he picked students from our
material science department which is
where Craig came from so we had a just a
wonderful time for the last hour to
talking with some graduate students from
material science and engineering and
hearing
bit about with what they're up to Craig
also suggested he'd like to share some
thoughts this evening about research
universities technology innovation and
21st century competitiveness and this is
a set of topics I think that all of us
care a lot about and Craig has its
thought deeply about all of these topics
and so I think we're really looking
forward to his comments on these topics
and he's promised that he will leave
time at the end for questions debate
challenges however you want to want to
put it because some of these topics are
clearly somewhat controversial so Craig
as all of you know is best known for his
career at Intel although that's only one
of many things that he's done he was he
spent 35 years of the company and held
positions vice-president senior vice
president and executive vice president
and later became president and CEO and
then chairman of the board in 2005 and
Craig is really credited with
transforming Intel into the
manufacturing powerhouse that it is
today and I think Intel is widely
regarded as the premier manufacturing
company certainly in the semiconductor
field but arguably in a much broader set
of fields as well and a lot of this has
to do with the manufacturing discipline
that Craig instilled in Intel
manufacturing plants that philosophy
called copy exactly which means if it
works do it again the same way and so
he's been recognized in many many
different ways for the contributions he
made to the company the National Academy
of Engineering he has received several
honorary doctorates in addition to his
real doctorate that he got here at
Stanford and right
and he actually I actually learned this
by you know if you if you google people
you can learn interesting things and so
I did that this afternoon I learned by
googling your Craig that you actually
have the equivalent of a knighthood in
Malaysia so I'm not sure I'm not sure
what that says about how we have to
refer to you but whatever you tell us
will do obviously so so Craig retired as
from Intel in 2009 he's also really well
and widely known for his tireless
advocacy for improving education in this
country and there's been a real focus on
k-12 education I think Craig will share
some thoughts about that in his remarks
in just a minute but he's he's been a
real national spokesperson an advocate
for the value that technology can
provide to education in foreign and
trying to set up a value system that
improves our k-12 education I think all
of us care a lot about that and will be
very interested to hear Craig's comments
he's had holds or has held many
positions associated with his interest
in in education until 2009 he was
chairman of the United Nations Global
Alliance for information and
communications technologies development
which was focused on bringing computers
and other technology to developing parts
of the world and he currently is
involved I could spend the whole evening
talk of what the things he's involved in
here but it's mentioned a couple he
serves on the council for Foreign
Relations Task Force on us education
reform he chairs the change the equation
organization which is a national
education science technology engineering
and math coalition he chairs achieve
which is a national nonpartisan
educational reform organization led by a
board of governors and business leaders
and finally he chairs the Arizona
governor's Arizona ready education
council so you can see spending a lot of
time thinking and working on educational
issues he's also been very deeply
involved with charter schools in Arizona
and other parts of the country and he's
thought really deeply about how to
improve the k-12 education system in
this country
now of course those of us here at
Stanford also know there's a third part
of Craig's career that we're incredibly
proud of in addition to the other two
and that's the time that he spent here
as a student and later as a faculty
member at Stanford so he earned
bachelor's master's and his real
doctorate in in material science and
engineering here at Stanford and he
served actually on the faculty here of
our material science department for 10
years until he was lured away by Intel
where he had the career I just described
a minute ago now even in the time he was
here at Stanford teaching he had a
research group and students and he
published a bunch of papers wrote a
quite famous textbook well think was
co-authored with Bill Nix who's also
here tonight welcome bill and so tonight
really these three aspects of craig's
life the time you spent here at Stanford
and as a student and as a faculty member
that the time he spent doing just
amazing things at one of the great
companies in this country and then
finally his passion and contributions to
education in this nation I think are all
of the reasons why we honor him tonight
as an engineering hero
so I will put this in the bank so you
can carry it but this is a replica of
the plaque that sits on the wall just
outside around the corner which you can
put on your desk and it made out of
silicon right it's made out of silicon
thats good good anything could get back
pretty well good evening everyone it's
just it's such a pleasure to be back
stanford although I have to say Stanford
didn't quite look like this when I was
here it's Dean plumber has had quite a
building spree going on and this
engineering quad there is quite
fantastic and it's especially nice to
see some of the old material science
people that I used to kick around with
over the years unfortunately they look
about as old as I look I arrived on this
campus in 1957 I grew up with a small
town to the north of here San Carlos
went to calm on high school there and
migrated my way 6.7 miles south to
campus when I right here in 1957
University looked a little different
there were still trolley tracks up from
downtown Palo Alto to the main quad you
did not have to have a parking sticker
there were no parking lots or parking
structures good park anywhere you could
find a parking place and perhaps the
most significant difference was tuition
was two hundred fifty dollars a quarter
having sent one of my grandkids through
here recently I can attest that the
tuition has gone up in some degree but
the university has changed obviously a
heck of a lot since nineteen fifty-seven
and correspondingly the rest of the
world has also changed quite a lot and I
wanted to really talk a little bit about
those changes tonight and maybe even
give you some ideas about things the
United States could do and I know there
are a lot of foreign nationals in the
audience and so I'm I won't dwell so
much on the u.s. although being a US
citizen I'm very concerned about the
future the United States but a lot of
things I say I think will carry
significance to other countries as well
as United States I wanted to start out
with just a very simple observation I
spent 35 years in the high-tech business
and there's a one rule in the high-tech
business and that is that market shares
are won and lost during periods of
transition technology transition market
transition any sort of transition you
can think about those are the times when
market shares are won and lost and if
you want to put that in current
perspective you could think back 25
years ago motorola was the key
communication company in the world
especially in handsets they lost that to
a finished company called nokia when
there was a transition from analog to
digital handsets nokia has succeeded in
losing their predominant position with
the advent of the smartphone recently so
you can see huge market share shifts
when a technology transition comes about
it's usually pretty hard to get to win
market share away when it's a static
market and you just attack the other
person when try to offer something a
little cheaper a little bit better but
there's no big transition occurring the
reason I bring that topic up is if you
look at the world in the last 20 years I
think you've seen the biggest
transition that the free world economic
system has ever seen and that started
with the ending of the cold war between
US and Russia which opened up Russia and
Eastern Europe to the world's free
economic system about the same time
India moved away from an isolationist
socialistic approached joined the free
economic system about the same time
China did exactly the same thing several
South American countries to the same
thing several other Southeast Asian
countries did the same thing then that
result of all that is the world's free
economic system which had been a very
controlled place Western Europe Japan
and the u.s. three roughly equivalent
geographic areas population standard of
living all of a sudden had an influx of
three billion new capitalists and the
world's economic system and if you want
a transition that's a transition half of
the world's population almost overnight
jumps from isolationist socialist
approach to a free market capitalist
approach the reason I dwell on that for
a moment is in fact we're undergoing
that transition still today and it's
likely that market shares substantial
world economic market shares will be won
and lost as this transition continues to
play out and the United States being the
strongest economic power going into that
transition probably has a much higher
probability of losing market share than
gaining market share and we'll come back
to that moment so that's one general
observation another general observation
is one that the reason you're all here
at Stanford is your standard of living
the standard of living of any population
any society depends on how much value
add you can put into what you do in your
professional life and so your salary
your standard of living depends on your
education which determines if you can
add value to what you do so education is
incredibly important third general
observation is I think pretty obvious
with the advent of the Internet
and the opening of the world to a a pre
market capitalist system that
information and money flows very freely
you all know that and go to the internet
and find out anything you know there are
some IP restrictions on how information
flows but pretty much information flows
freely across borders and money is very
liquid and flows to the point of highest
return and so investments today are made
on a worldwide basis not on a local
basis and if you have a good environment
for investments you can attract
investments if you don't have a good
environment you lose out on those
investments and i'll make some mentions
relative to the US on investment
strategy and environment in a few
moments and you all know because you're
techies that that this is a century of
innovation and technology and its minds
and not brawn that are going to succeed
but those are the general rules the
biggest rule Biggers two rules are
really education super important and
market shares are won and lost in
periods of transition we're in the
biggest transition you've ever seen now
if you believe that societies or
cultures or countries can do something
about their economic future and I've had
the ability to travel to about 130 or
hundred and forty different countries
and talk to leaders government leaders
academic leaders business leaders in
those countries and you ask them what
are they doing it turns out it always
boils down to the same three things
countries have three levers they can
pull to try to influence their economic
future and the first lever is not
surprisingly education how well do you
educate your populace your workforce how
much value add can they do and a well
educated individual is just a super
super powerful thing and I just wanted
to give you I'll try to interject a few
examples from my past at Intel as we go
through here in the mid-70s shortly
after I joined the company in the main
product that we had was something called
a 4k dynamic Ram
most of you young people have never seen
a fork a dynamic ramps I was a
magnificent upgrade from the 1103 which
was a 1k dynamic Ram but we were making
pork a dynamic Rams and we were shipping
them to Western Electric to put in PB
X's and so what they would do is they
would program the pbx with all the phone
numbers and extensions and things like
that and there was was a great
improvement over old magnetic core
memory and the previous solutions but
there was one minor problem these 4k
dynamic Rams occasionally would drop a
bit and that did not make Western
Electric happy Wes electric by the way
was the manufacturing arm of Bell
Telephone the big monopoly at that time
so I was running reliability engineer
engineering at Intel the time and I at a
frequent flyer plane ticket from Silicon
Valley to Denver where Western Electric
was making these PB X's and we had the
best minds and Western Electric and had
a lot of great minds there and that
Intel trying to figure out why these for
KD Rams occasionally dropped a bit it
was a soft drop you know dynamic Ram bit
for those of you are not into those
circuits is basically a little capacitor
and it's a one if you have some
electrons and it's a zero if you don't
so dropping a bit Masek basically meant
you either lost some electrons or gain
some electrons in that capacitor problem
was solved by a well-educated super
smart individual when the total
technical forces of Intel and Western
Electric were unable to solve the
problem and the solution went something
like this this young man his name is Tim
May had heard Gordon Moore give a speech
Gordon Moore was talking about Moore's
law and so we were in now in the mid-70s
Gordon Moore postulated Moore's law in
the mid-60s so he had 10 years of
shrinking dimensions and so forth and
Gordon said effectively hey you know if
you would keep this up for a long long
time the dimensions will get so small
that there's a possibility
that circuits could be corrupted or
altered by some things like cosmic rays
coming in from the universe and hitting
the circuit making something happen and
Tim had taken that to heart and he
started thinking about that and then he
started thinking okay these dynamic Rams
are put in ceramic packages ceramics or
basic aluminum oxide but they might have
small amounts of impurities some of
those impurities might be radioactive
they might be admitting things like
alpha particles if one of those alpha
particles were to hit the surface of the
dye and create electron hole pairs and
those electrons were collected in one of
these little capacitors of this one of
the bits of dynamic ram they could shift
at state any was just thinking like this
by himself he wasn't chartered to work
on this problem he wasn't no one was
depending on him to solve the problem so
late one night he got a whole bunch of
ceramic piece parts packages they sort
of made out put him in essentially a
Geiger counter let it count all night
with the parts in it let it count all
next night without the parts in it
determined there was a slight
radioactive content to these parts and
then the conclusive experiment Eve he
demonstrated was in fact it was a small
amount of thorium in the aluminum oxide
which was radioactive was decaying
giving off alpha particles the way
demonstrated this absolutely was to go
to the ultimate alpha particle source
which you all know is a smoke detectors
smoke detectors work by sending out
alpha particles ionized smoke particles
collect them so forth really ought to
study smoke detectors
but Tim knocked the cap off of some of
these coke ad Rams which were in a
memory board thought the alpha-particle
source right to the top of the package
and was able depending on how close you
got get a 10 or 12 order of magnitude
increase in the soft error rate the
higher the alpha particle density on the
surface if you know a little bit about
alpha particles they don't penetrate
very far but the active surface of the
silicon circuit is not very far below
the passivation layer put a piece of
scotch tape on it that absorbs all the
alpha particles so you could solve the
problem pretty easily but it was one
smart guy thinking out of the box with a
good education it was able to out do a
whole team of Western Electric and until
researchers were working on this problem
for weeks education is so important
smart guys and gals are so important so
that's the first lever people have is
education that's how you justify a high
standard of living you add value to what
you do the second societal strategy is
investing in ideas and that's rd and we
could go on all night with great rd that
goes on here at Stanford not only in the
engineering school but in the university
as a whole or the collection of research
universities in the United States but
you just think of the industry I've been
in and the folks back at Bell Labs
bardeen herring Shockley creation of the
transistor back in 50s Jack Kilby Bob
Noyce at Fairchild and TI separately
research figuring out the integrated
circuit Ted HOF Frederico vagine Stan
maser creating the first four bit micro
processors at Intel investment in
research creates the next generation of
products the next generation of
businesses the next generation of
services is a great correlation around
the world for economies the percentage
of the gdp that goes into research and
the
growth of those economies they're
creating this seed corn the ideas of the
future so you have two levers so far one
is you need smart people next one is you
need to invest in new ideas smart people
smart ideas and the only third lever
that exists for any economy any society
is to allow smart people to get together
with smart ideas and do something
wonderful you have just a great example
right here Silicon Valley Stanford UC
Berkeley that hurts me to say UC
Berkeley but but they've been a critical
part of Silicon Valley the two great
universities research universities
spinning off smart people and smart
ideas a venture capital community a
society that does not frown on failure
it's not a cultural norm around the
world who like failure but Silicon
Valley loves failure gives you
experience that's the right environment
to do something wonderful by the way
California is struggling today on
continuing to be the right environment
for smart people to get together with
smart ideas in terms of its tax
structure its regulatory structure its
deficit structure its disinvestment in
education it's struggling to keep that
but certainly Silicon Valley route 128
outside of MIT and Harvard is another
area Austin Texas is another area some
of the Midwest research universities or
wonderful areas the right environment to
do right things those are the only three
things you have if you're in charge of a
government or in charge of an economy to
stimulate that economy's growth smart
people smart ideas and then the right
environment to let those two get
together and do something now what are
people around the world doing today you
know Silicon Valley has been recognized
by everybody the Russians are trying to
copy Silicon Valley right now place
called skok oval cut a deal with MIT
create an MIT like research university
try to build
on the Russian heritage of academics and
research but no commercialization but
trying to build on what MIT is done to
bring industry close to the University
much like Dean plumber is done at
Stanford to bring local industry close
to the School of Engineering no matter
where you go in the world just about
every country is trying to copy Stanford
or MIT or caltech they premier us
research university every European
country is trying to move their
universities more towards the Western
the u.s. model not have it as an ivory
tower but have it work closely with
industry back and forth exchange of
people and ideas work on real problems
not only are people trying to copy US
universities but US universities have a
thriving business projecting themselves
to the rest of the world you cannot go
to a Chinese University and not find
half a dozen Western universities
they're exchanging faculty curricula
research projects from an industrial
perspective I've always found it very
interesting I think us research
universities are the national treasure
there are no restrictions on them
transferring you guys transferring your
capability outward if you work at a
technology company there's all sorts of
restrictions on transferring your
technology it's an interesting dichotomy
but the rest of the world has recognized
the power the research university I was
when I talk to groups I like to give a
simple example of how powerful research
universities are and the power of a
single idea most of you in the audience
have heard of Microsoft pretty big
company pretty big research budget
probably they their research budget
today is eight to nine billion dollars a
year Microsoft has been seriously
challenged three or four times in its
career
none of those challenges have come from
other companies with equally large
research budgets the challenges have not
come from IBM they've not come from sa p
or oracle or HP or intel or anybody of
that sort if you just look at
microsoft's history where to have the
corporate challenge has been the
internet browser came from
superconducting laboratory at the
universe fill annoy the internet
directory where to come from jim
stanford university the internet search
engine were to come from google stanford
university each one of those projects
was not a big research project one or
two researchers with a bright idea
ladies and gentlemen that is the power
of the individual idea it can take down
the largest corporation that's why
research universities are so powerful
they cultivate smart people to be
creative and come out with brilliant
ideas the rest of the world is trying to
copy that and yet there are other
techniques as well the country of Chile
has a couple of universities not very
highly ranked in the world i think the
highest ranked university in chile is
right number 350 or so but someone in
the government there said you know if we
could make chili entrepreneurial we
might be able to stimulate our economy
and really short circuit this university
stuff so chilly goes out and starts to
give $50,000 grants to entrepreneurs who
want to go to santiago and create a
business and it's amazing how far you
can spread ten million dollars in
$50,000 grants and they're bringing
every six months 100 or 200 new ideas
entrepreneurial startups in to santiago
most of them are software and social
software type startups
but smart people with smart ideas
jump-starting the economy as I mentioned
the Russians are trying to do this the
Irish are trying to do this the Chinese
are trying to do this everyone has
recognized there are three lovers you
pull those three lovers you can get
results the one thing that I think is
clear traveling the world and looking at
what's happening is what doesn't work
protecting your economy with tariffs
doesn't work not working hard doesn't
work not committing to serious
educational attainment doesn't work it's
hard work but everybody else in the
world is trying to do this so what about
the USA Today richest country in the
world has been for 50 years beneficiary
of World War two when every other
economy was destroyed beneficiary of an
immigration policy which allowed the
best and brightest from the world to
come to the u.s. beneficiary of the best
university system in the world but
having problems the national academies
about seven years ago did a study of the
US economy and the future of the US
economy is called risin by the Gathering
Storm national academy of science
national academy of engineering
institute of medicine looked at this
problems the US was having educational
infrastructure problems the decrease in
the relative percentage of gdp going
into R&D tax structure which was not
incentivizing investment us boats
incentivizing investment out of the
united states an immigration policy that
defies explanation or imagination and I
had dinner tonight with a bunch of
students from the material science
department at least half of them are
foreign nationals the US has an
immigration policies that says let's
educate
the best and brightest in the world at
US taxpayer expense and send them home
you cannot find a single person in
Washington DC who will not agree with
you when you say that's a dumb idea and
a dumb strategy you cannot find a single
person but when you get two of them or
more in a room they refuse to do
anything about it and still refuse to do
anything about it I can remember about
15 to 20 years ago at Intel we were
lobbying for immigration reform and came
up with the idea of stapling a green
card to a an advanced degree from a u.s.
University that as at least now made it
after 15 to 20 years to the staple act
which has never made it out of committee
yet in the house but a very very simple
solution to a complex seemingly complex
problem there are a couple of other
interesting observations you can make as
Jim mentioned I've served on a council
on foreign relations study many of you
probably aren't familiar with the
Council on Foreign Relations they're
really interested in national security
issues primarily so you ask what is the
organization that worries about national
security worrying about education for
and they worry about it for two reasons
one which is an extremely sobering
statistic and one which is more of a
philosophical issue the philosophic
issue is national security is
increasingly not military security its
economic security you can't have
economic security unless you have a good
education system so the decline of the K
through 12 education system in the u.s.
leads the Council on Foreign Relations
to worry about k12 education reform the
practical statistic that they note is if
you take a random selection of 18 to 24
year olds
the United States seventy-five percent
or more of them are ineligible for
service in the military for one of three
reasons they are physically unfit can't
pass the physical exam they're
incarcerated probably don't want them in
the military they can't pass the
educational requirements to get into the
military over seventy-five percent of
our young people are not eligible for
military service so you had a committee
chaired by condi rice great Stanford
talent and Joel Klein who used to run
the New York City school system conclude
exactly the same thing about k12
education reform that a dozen other
studies over the last 50 years have
concluded you need great teachers you
need high expectations and you need some
tension I'll talk a little bit about
that emitted you have a couple of other
aspects of the US which are a little bit
troubling to one is a comment that Laura
Tyson made and laura tyson i think still
runs AHA's business school or its
business school professor of a berkeley
she was clinton's economic advisor when
asked if the universities in the US were
doing a good job educating people for
the future and the jobs of the future
she said well yes and then when asked
what the jobs for the future were in the
united states she said well the main
ones are going to be health care and
education and that as she said it it
kind of sounded right health care is
growing education is growing employs a
lot of people but then if you start to
think about it for a minute what pays
for education and health care jobs
unless you're educated less you're
exporting education Stanford does a
pretty good job at that it's an income
source
unless you're exporting healthcare make
an income source it's a drain on society
because tax pays for it individuals pay
for its not a value creation exercise
diet creation exercises where you make
something or you have a service that
people buy from you not your self
servicing your population so I was a
little concerned when presidential
economic advisor was not concerned at
all that were not educating people to
create value to grow our economy or
educating people to sustain our economy
and health care and education so where
are we today sky David Walker anybody
heard of David Walker ok you get
educated David was a comptroller general
from nineteen ninety eight to two
thousand eight comfort allure general
United States that's the guy who
basically looks at the books of the
United States and tries to balance the
budget and tells you when you're
spending too much David spent ten years
traveling United States and he's still
doing it today for the pete peterson
foundation which is kind of picked up on
what Walker was saying that this is
totally unstable situation you're
spending way more than you can afford to
spend you're going into debt the
unfunded liabilities of health care and
pensions and all that is way out of
whack you need to do one of a couple
things either need to stop spending so
much or get more revenue that's kind of
what the whole presidential campaign has
been about stop spending so much or get
more revenue mr. Walker started that
speech about 14 years ago unfortunately
nobody has done anything about it in
those 14 years but we'll get to that in
a minute so we're deep in debt in the
u.s. sixteen billion dollars we're
spending a trillion dollars more each
year than we take in we slept in
education and let me give you the one I
think most damaging education statistics
that's the parent not a K through 12
education statistic but a post-secondary
education statistic the United States
used to be number one in the world in
the percentage of its workforce with a
post-secondary degree number one in the
world where is it today in the OECD
countries is somewhere between number 13
and number 14 over the last 20 or 30
years we are the essentially the only
osed country economically developed
country or the fraction of our workforce
with the post-secondary degree and the
basically 55 to 65 category is higher
than it is in the 25 to 35 category
we're the only country where there's
been a slight decrease in a percentage
of our workforce with a post-secondary
degree when you hear the presidential
candidates talking about returning the
American middle class the high paying
jobs you have to think seriously about
the skill set of that middle class to
use their brains to add value to what
they do without massive retraining and
as long as you see the United States
continuing to slip in the rankings of
its workforce with a percentage of
post-secondary degrees you have to worry
about the United States economy going
forward how can I justify having the
highest standard of living middle class
the size of its head the other thing
obviously is math and science competency
of our young people essure you've all
seen the TV ads that Exxon has been
running and other companies have been
running the results of the nape test of
the peas or tests any of the
international benchmark tests will show
the u.s. kids who used to rank very high
in math and science now rank and then
essentially the bottom quartile of the
OECD countries in those topic
and they're not getting any better other
countries are improving faster than the
slow improvement we're getting and the
last characteristic I'd say that we have
today is characterized by California you
have a proposition in front of you to
raise taxes next Tuesday you're going to
have the highest personal income tax in
the US you're going to drive more of
your wealthy people out we've been ten
when I was at Intel we told four
consecutive governor's we'd never put
another manufacturing plant in this
state they didn't believe us we didn't
California is a little bit symptomatic
of the rest of the United States if you
want to compete you have to provide an
environment where there's some incentive
to invest not disincentives to invest
and a lot of the United States hasn't
learned that lesson and I've California
is a probably a particularly strong
example of that so having laid out this
very optimistic position I will now want
to switch roles and be optimistic
permitted and what I want to do is just
take a minute to tell you if I were
running for president which I am NOT but
if I were what i would suggest could be
done in a heartbeat to make this
situation a lot better and to build on
some of the strengths we have and also
to correct some of the weaknesses that
we have and I'm not going to touch on
the issues of social security and health
care as Social Security is a trivial
fixed and and once you get beyond the
emotion of Social Security and you say
i'm going to extend the retirement age
by a couple of years and make it a
means-tested payout Social Security
takes care of itself it's just getting
over the emotion of doing those two
things which are kind of trivial with
current life expectancy and the fact
that wealthy people kind of like myself
I get my Social Security check each
month which I give immediately to
charity but I still get it I don't need
it so a means testing and a site
extension of the retirement age would
take care of Social Security health care
is more difficult we could talk about
health care and the question answer
session but I've got equally simple
solutions there much simpler than
Obamacare hi I guarantee you but I think
there are about five things you could do
almost instantaneously to get the us
back on the right track the first one
obviously involves where we are today
research universities really the heart
and soul of the United States economy
because this is where the new ideas and
the smart people come from this is
something we have been proposing for
decades but you could do it overnight
and it is not a big deal from a
financial standpoint it is from the
results but not from the input financial
side I would double or treble NSF budget
NIH budget the do e research budget any
basic research budget the United States
had government has that they farm out to
our tier1 research universities to
conduct that research I would just
double or treble it overnight and then
reap the benefits as time would go on
we've been lobbying that for years the
rising above the gathering storm reports
from the National Academies said double
it but I think you could do even more
any idea what the NSF budget annual
budget is it is a rounding error folks
the rounding error compared to what we
spend on other things and i'll tell you
how to pay for it just a moment I would
have a sensible immigration policy I
would staple a green card permanent
residency card for any graduate of any
of a select number of STEM fields or
anybody who graduates from a u.s.
University I would just staple a green
card they also make it easy for foreign
nationals to come with a green card to
the US that fixes legal immigration
overnight it doesn't fix the illegal
immigration problem but quite frankly
the legal immigration problem is the
critical one from an economic driving
force not illegal immigration and you
could fix that almost overnight
President Obama tried to fix the illegal
immigration problem with an executive
order I wish he had an executive order
as strong on the legal immigration side
that would allow the best and the
brightest to continue to come to the
u.s. and ply their trades
how do I pay for doubling or tripling
the research budgets this is where I get
into trouble with some of my industrial
peers I would cut every government
subsidy to the corporate world 20 forget
about ethanol forget about green energy
forget about R&D tax credits Dean
plumbers still on the intel board and he
should cringe when I say forget about rd
tax credits but I would cut all
government subsidies and I've we return
to a capitalist society government
doesn't pick winners and losers
government doesn't give subsidies to
companies companies make it on their own
at the same time at the same time I
would lower the corporate tax rate to an
internationally competitive level to
incentivize corporate investment in the
United States corporate tax rate in the
u.s. is about the highest in the world
tenth of a percentage point below Japan
it needs to go from its thirty five to
forty percent depending if you add state
and federal taxes together it needs to
go from that to the fifteen percent
range to incentivize investments in the
United States to create jobs but cutting
subsidies I think would more than pay
for the cut in tax rate and would more
than pay the increase in rd item for my
platform k through 12 education the
United States has gone from the envy of
the world educating our young people to
a mediocre state today and it's been
mediocre for quite some time gentlemen
by name is James Harvey in 1983 authored
something called a nation at risk 1983 a
long time ago
nation at risk built on a previous
publication published in 1958 called
pursuit of excellence but mr. Harvey
said in 1983 if a foreign nation had
imposed upon the United States the
mediocrity of our current education
system we would consider it an act of
war it's a very strong statement 1983 30
years ago and that built on a study
which was done in 58 and every study
since then has said exactly the same
thing that those studies have said which
is you need systemic fixed at K through
12 education the systemic pics is like
every other country that has a good
education system I qualified motivated
professionally compensated teachers high
expectations and some tension in the
system and you asked what tension is
tension is competition is pay for
performance it's closing down failing
schools it's choice so my fourth
platform item involves buying a whole
bunch of backpacks I want to give every
five year old in the United States a
backpack and you ask why because every
fall I want that child to go to the
state and get their backpack filled up
with the ten thousand dollars or so a
year that the state spends on education
give it to that child and their family
and then let the family spend that money
to get that child educated wherever they
want they want to go to public school
the kid takes her backpack to a public
school gives them the money they want to
go to a charter school private school of
parochial school I don't care what it is
we've talked for 55 years about
reforming k through 12 education the
only real reform we have is that 40
states have
form of competition limited competition
mostly in terms of charter schools we
need more competition more choice if you
want the current system to change so
every kid gets a backpack and the money
follows the kid the kid doesn't go to
the school where the money goes the
adults in this system have proven
themselves incapable of doing a good job
let the parents and the kid decide where
to go to get educated I do not make many
friends and the teachers unions but that
is precisely the problem it's not the
teachers that's a problem and it's not
just the teachers union is to establish
bureaucracy that we have put in place
that preserves the status quo you know
there's a couple of great quotes here
that you probably heard about K through
12 education one was from a president of
the teachers union which basically said
when the kids start paying union dues
then we'll worry about them
and the other quote is obviously this
system is built for the adults it's not
built for the children choice vouchers
whatever you want to call it i think is
absolutely here we have some great
public schools now my kids went to gun
high school still a great high school
any kid that goes that high school gets
a great education that is an outlier in
the united states what happens at Henry
gun high school it is not typical I
would have no hesitation sending the
child to gun high school however most of
the other high schools in the United
States would not be worthy of my child
to go to okay item five you may suspect
that I have Republican leanings i'm not
going to differ with the republican
party i want to freeze the defense
budget until further notice fact if I
could have a job in the future my job
would be as secretary defense with no
salary but getting ten percent of all
the savings I could achieve the
Secretary of Defense that's not the only
condition the other condition is I would
not have a board of directors of 535
people that is the house and the Senate
can you imagine running a business where
every decision you make is
second-guessed and overruled by anybody
who has their district to have something
to do with that decision you're making
and that's exactly what we have today
just put in perspective the United
States spends about 750 billion a year
on defense if you rank that relative to
the other countries in the world we
spend more than the next 17 combined
that's probably enough I'm just going to
freeze it I'm not going to cut it I just
freeze it at 750 and then let's get on
with our life and that's going to pay
for some of these other programs most of
all the reason I kind of lay those four
five items out are you have to make up
your mind that you're going to compete
in the 21st century it's a huge
transition it is the biggest economic
transition the world has ever seen half
of the world's population overnight
changing sides three billion new
capitalists you either choose to compete
you lose market share and the current
state is that the u.s. hasn't made up
its mind to compete it's blaming China
for this is blaming somebody for that
blaming the other party for this when in
fact it's the fundamentals that have to
be fixed so why am I really excited I
think the 21st century has got such
great opportunity because of places like
stamping I mean the marriage of biology
and engineering is just starting just
getting off the map the whole biotech
revolution is just beginning something
very close to my heart the marriage of
electronics and photonics is just
starting and some of the work that
happens to be taking place at Intel
silicon lasers detectors the ability on
a single integrated silicon chip to put
photonic devices and electronic devices
means Moore's law just gets to go
bananas for the next couple of decades
but some basic technology that
originated here x-ray free-electron
laser demonstrated Stanford Lawrence
Berkeley Lab up across the bay wants to
build a great next-generation light
source hugely more powerful x-ray laser
and just yeah I mean if you want to
start to think about studying molecular
reactions or atomic reactions just think
about it basically a pulse coherent
x-ray laser where you can effectively
image atoms or molecules and chemical
reactions like a strobe light
bouncing around 100 million frames a
second I mean these things are exciting
I'm there credibly exciting credibly
opportunity going forward I think this
university and Jim and I were talking
about this earlier today is in the midst
of a great transition I brought up
earlier and when I came here to ition
was 250 bucks a quarter seven hundred
fifty dollars a year it was
astronomically expensive at the time but
not as expensive as it is today and at
the current rate what happens to
Stanford in 20 years especially with the
onslaught of online education when you
can educate hundreds of thousands of
students online rather than a thousand
students in the classroom what is the
future of the University talk about a
transition who's going to be the winner
or loser in that transition and what
happens that's exciting that's
opportunity and if Stanford makes the
right choices then they blossom and they
gain market share going forward they
make the wrong choice they're like
Motorola in the cell phone and make the
right choice you know in textbooks I
have two grandkids both getting the
nba's one in Anderson School UCLA and
one at Northwestern and I my bankroll
their tuition and their books and such
and I get the bill each quarter for
their books you know it was mentioned
earlier that bill nicks and I
co-authored a textbook and bill what did
it sell for but it started fifteen
dollars fifteen dollars the book fee for
my two grandkids for each quarter is
somewhere between a thousand and fifteen
hundred dollars two hundred bucks a book
I think that's unstable and obviously
that's a transition and process of
happening going from hardcopy limited
edition to online these are the exciting
things going on in the future these are
the things that would be fun fun to be
involved with but back to the United
States I love to go to chinese food
restaurants for one very simple reason
the wisdom in the Chinese fortune cookie
is unbeatable it's never wrong it's
always right I want to give you two
fortune cookies tonight one is what
we've been talking about in terms of
education this comes how many of you
been to chef chu's down in El Camino my
favorite place great fortune cookie 10
or 15 years ago the world will always
accept talent with open arms what is
talent talent is education and passion
for what you do no matter what you do
want to be a poet position physicist
whatever if you have talent great
education and passion the world will
always accept you with open arms that's
me it's not just the education but it's
the education the passion that's the
talent second fortune cookie golden
Phoenix sixteenth street phoenix arizona
where i live these days
you cannot win unless you choose to
compete my contention is in the
transition we're seen in the world's
economic system your economy cannot win
unless you choose to compete and the way
you compete is to go back with the three
levers that I mentioned education
investment and ideas for the future and
then create the right environment so
that smart people get together with
smart ideas and do something I had hopes
in the presidential campaign this year
the topics that the presidential camp
candidates would talk about we're the
ones i listed tonight I've been somewhat
disappointed we have talked about rather
the capital of Israel should be
Jerusalem mortality we've talked about
how many times God should be in the
Democratic platform we've talked about
all of these topics but we haven't
really talked about the key ones i hope
the US under its new president or
extension of the current president
whoever gets elected next tuesday will
choose to compete thank you for your
time i'll try to answer any questions
you might have
yes it's really pretty simple model it's
back to the old HMO model what i would
do is is the thick of walmart or costco
or any of these Kmart those guys which
are integrated retailers I want an
integrated health care solution where in
fact the integrated healthcare provider
has all of the stuff that you need and
think of my competing super stores in
the corner you're able to go from one to
the other and your records follow you
but for one single fee they pay for your
entire healthcare coverage and then they
compete on the basis of performance
service etc but you have to have three
or four of them so you have choices in
this competition as opposed to the
fractured p for service system we have
today I don't think fee-for-service
you'll ever be able to modify it make it
effective there's attempts to integrate
you know virtually integrate the
different parts of it but I think you
take Kaiser Permanente or Intermountain
health it or any one of these guys which
is an integrated healthcare delivery /
deal Mayo Clinic another good example
but you need those on a large scale
which compete on the basis of quality
and customer service and price or a long
way from that and that's not really what
Obamacare is all about Obamacare doesn't
really give you a systemic change all
that it says is the government will
slash the amount it pays for something
or redirect you or deny you service this
is a totally capitalistic approach but
and let various people compete and then
the consumer gets to go to whoever does
the best job in a nutshell yeah loading
rooted and applying technology save all
this tissue
I have said for years that in response
to the question of if you had your
choice of one piece of technology to put
in the classroom to dramatically improve
education what would it be and my answer
hasn't changed it's a good teacher a
good teacher trumps all technology in
fact if you look at the United States as
an example and you said that you can
solve the problem with technology the US
has essentially way more technology in
the classrooms and essentially any other
country we ought to be winning on the
basis of our technology investment it's
not technology it's good teachers and
high expectations yes but observation
our k-12 education and I'd like to see
if you agree within and if you do how
how it fits in in the way you see things
and that is that k-12 education is the
only measured by its output but it has
inputs and outputs and especially in
California the inputs are troubled
dysfunctional families all sorts of
other problems people that don't speak
English coming in and in fact you can
predict outputs based on the parents
more than you can based on the schools
so if you look at k12 as a you know
inputs and outputs how do you measure
how well California is doing or or the
US and does that change your point of
view about how how bad our schools are
well the question is about inputs and
outputs in education and they're a bunch
of input variables input variables in
not only the nature of the family is
kind of an environmental input but
there's how many teachers you have for
kids or kids / teachers how big the
classroom is how much you pay your
teachers how many days you go to school
there are all sorts of input
variables one of the primary problems of
k-12 education has been an input driven
system with total ignoring the output
and the output is how much a kid learns
and if you run any company and you go to
Wall Street nobody gives a damn about
the input variables the only care about
the output and K through 12 is exactly
turned on its head in that respect it's
all input driven not output driven your
specific question about the
socio-economic background of the parents
and the parental support there's been a
lot of discussion about that but there
are a lot of great examples in the
poorest socio-economic environments
where schools have said I know that
everybody has a concern about this but
let's ignore that we get the kids eight
hours a day five days a week which is
more than their parents have them and
let's see what a grab we can do
educating them basically ignoring that
family background and they get some
fantastic results the problem is that
there's always something that gets in
the way of the output conveniently gets
in the way the output and it's only when
you say no the outputs the only
important thing that you get results and
to get results you always need kind of
the same three things you need great
teachers and other subject material you
need high expectations hey everybody in
this room was a kid right some of you
may still be but everybody in the room
was a kid when somebody told you to do
something as a kid they said jump this
high how high did you jump just to get
over that barrier and when I said jump
this high how high did you jump kids are
so flexible and adults the system does
not give them the credit they deserve
for how flexible and what they can
attain and the tension do you need the
system you need good teachers you need
high expectations of the tension is why
i want to buy every kid a backpack
the only way the system will change is
competition I give you a very simple
example I'm chairman of a charter school
system based in Arizona we just opened
our first school in washington DC not
known for its high academic achievement
washington DC not our school system our
school system is is pretty high level
and just give you an example typical kid
finishes their junior year in high
school they taken ten to twelve eight
taken and passed ten to twelve AP
courses by their junior year so pretty
high academic achievement we announce
we're going to Washington DC who
announced the location of our school the
three surrounding high schools to our
location immediately announced honors
programs which they did not have before
to try to satisfy the kids in those
schools who want honors programs or
advanced academic stuff just on the down
nouncement that we're coming that's what
competition buys you it wouldn't have
happened unless that announcement it
happen that we were coming to DC so I'm
now that we've got socio-economic stuff
all the hands are going up always
succeeding with all this back you know
the Nordic countries have historically
been very high in education spectrum
Finland especially although it's now got
some pretty good competition with some
of the city states and china shanghai in
those areas then let education system
kind of satisfies the three things as i
mentioned it's more difficult to get
into a teaching school or get accepted
in the teaching profession in finland
than it is to get into Stanford's
engineering school teaching is held in
very high esteem in Finland you get and
track the best and brightest so you get
very good teachers secondly they measure
themselves on an international basis
whatever Pisa
you name the international test that's
how they grade themselves and they do a
very good job proactively with tension
in the system by trying to help
struggling students or teachers or
administrators they kind of satisfy the
three basic requirements the United
States in contrast every study has shown
that a school of education in the United
States typically attracts the bottom
twenty-five percent of college entrance
you skew the School of Education you
skew the teacher population to the down
side where the Nordic countries skew it
to the upside and then you get the net
result of that out Korea similar type of
deal china similar type of deal yes way
in the back like to bring the
conversation back to technology
investment and silicon valley venture
capitalists you know he really made this
place what it is today and right now at
least for the last several years they've
been heavily investing in social media
web two point O companies um what do you
think it's going to take to get the
venture capital community back focused
on investing in real high tech
entrepreneurship semiconductor heavy
manufacturing and severally well it's
you know that I my opinion is the these
venture capital community made a bet
about a 10 or 12 years ago on
infrastructure type investments they're
all green and they were enamored with
making green investments I think made a
fundamental mistake when they made those
investments because frankly every one of
those investments required something
called a subsidy from the US government
to be successful but a lot of those
investments were heavy duty investments
i mean the cylinder atty things and that
sort of stuff BrightSource these are
huge infrastructure investments a lot of
VC money went into those I think the
mistake was made
who depend on the subsidy from the
government as a viable business model I
think I was kind of burned the venture
capital community for a period of time
social media is a very low
infrastructure investments and so you're
looking for some fast returns to replace
those returns I wish that those guys had
not made those green investments that
they had continued to look make
capitalist investments without any
government subsidy attached way in the
back let's just see your master the gent
universe and you could assemble a
consortium of companies to deal with
apples who would you want to try to
assemble together and what would you
think about strategy that make it worse
well Intel would be high on my list you
know I think that Apple under steve jobs
steve was a master at human interface
and reading what to put in the market at
the right time and you go back to the
iPod the iPod was about the 30th mp3
player that came out it just had a bit
better form factor it had Steve's
association with Hollywood and the music
companies who was able to package itunes
and a nice device which nobody else did
so it was what the customer wanted and
you know the guy with the computer next
to you which has an intel chip in it you
know as a nice user interface and a
pretty good operating system and so
forth iphone and ipad or you know
similar type devices if i was going to
assemble a team yeah i'd sure like a
good human interface team maybe I'd go
over the d.school here gym and get some
of your bright folks out of there I'd
certainly want some severe electronic
technology inside for the fastest
processors and memory devices and
solid-state drives and some good display
technology and then I'd work like heck
to get the apps community behind me
is the major part of the human interface
is going to be all the apps that go with
it as he's showing us now as he turns a
computer around yes yes the brain
population oh is it great Alan cool to
see how can they just one of those um
struggling with a question okay for the
green properties the grain population
I'm greater than you are okay what
recommendations all into the policy
makers never stop learning is the best
advice I I mean least have a saying that
Intel which was your college education
your university education had a
half-life of about three or four years
and so the minute you stop learning you
start going out of date and I think this
is by implication when when the
presidential candidates in the US or in
any country are talking about the middle
class and how to restore the middle
class I don't see how it can be done
without infusing in the middle class a
new set of skills which means you can't
stop learning you can't stop advancing
so my advice to my kids and grandkids is
don't stop learning my advice to us
would be exactly the same you have to do
something new all the time or you're
going to be out of date and I think
that's especially to Moore's law is not
slowing down you know and the rurals
economic environment is not slowing down
so either you continually get new skills
adapt new skills to the new environment
or you fall behind and so part of
deciding that if you want to win you
have to choose to compete choosing to
compete is learning new skills beach
well you know if there if if you're past
your retirement age and you have a
retirement then I guess you get your
choice of of learning something or you
know being a couch potato but if you're
still in your professional career your
working years and my mind you really
have no choice you either do it or you
fall behind and and that is the whole
issue that i was talking about if you
want to win you have to choose to
compete and most people who want a nice
salary in a nice home and a nice
standard of living the norm in the rule
today is if you want that you have to
choose to compete you have no other
option one one last question women in
the workforce but the attrition rate for
women in STEM careers is very rapid and
there's well no research that attest to
this fact what responsibility should the
u.s. have to the private sector have to
prevent the attrition of women in the
stampedes I'm not sure that the that
there is a responsibility to prevent
attrition and the female workforce I
think there's a responsibility to
provide equal opportunity to women in
the professional workforce and that good
that starts all the way in k to 12 when
you unfortunately turn off a lot of
young girls on math and science and onto
the universities to get I don't know
what your distribution of male/female
school of engineering is today it's it's
getting better
that is the sort of answer you get in
the political theater we could ask you
more specifically could you give us a
percentage yes I can at the
undergraduate level the School of
Engineering is about thirty percent
women but you have to go deeper than
that because some majors are fifty
percent women and some majors are
fifteen percent women and the question
we need to ask i think is why are some
of them fifty percent then why are some
of them 15% and especially why is
computer science one of the fifteen
percent when there are so many
opportunities here in the valley for
computer science graduates so it's it's
it's it's a deeper question than just
the single single number you know it I I
fully expect was I know the situation at
Intel which is every major corporation
faces that issue and then tries to have
the right environment for equal
opportunity for women equal advancement
opportunities educational opportunities
management opportunities or technical
track opportunities at the depending on
what the individual wants but it's
pretty clear that that is one of the key
factors as well as women tend to lag
behind in their participation but
minorities like other minorities like
behind as well so usually you'll see
parallel efforts on Hispanics African
Americans women and if you're in a know
a geography will you have a lot of
Native Americans they usually are kind
of at the bottom end of that
distribution as well and a lot of social
economic things you have to do to
include those different groups in the
Equal Opportunity clause so I really
sorry we have to cut this off at this
point but Craig has a plane to catch it
has to leave in about 20 minutes or
something like that but there is a
reception outside there's drinks and a
little bit of food and so on we would
encourage you to stay around meet old
friends talk to back to new friends and
Craig will I'm sure be avail
all the chat perfumer miss but Craig
thank you you're you're our hero
you